hi everyone welcome to the video series
of piyo techniques explained in five
minutes where I explained our concept of
biology in less than five minutes if you
haven't here to subscribe to my channel
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to leave a comment after the
video because that's what keep me
motivated right so today's installment
we would learn about flow cytometry so
before starting and learning about flow
cytometry we should understand what is
the use of flow cytometry in modern day
research
flow cytometry could be used to sort
cells according to size or cellular
complexity it could also be used to sort
cells by fluorescence based approaches
it could be used to analyze cell cycle
cell viability and many other aspects
now we should look at the mechanisms and
the several components of the flow
cytometer and thereby we can understand
and appreciate the principles the
physical principle the physics behind
the flow cytometry so let's discuss the
parts of the flow cytometry one by one
in a very simplistic manner first of all
flow cytometry the heart of the flow
cytometry is to have a good fluidic
system we will talk a lot about the
fluidic system because the principles
which are used in this fluidic system is
very important then a detection system
so a light is required to illuminate the
samples it's not similar like a
microscope so the laser modules are
important component now the lasers that
are emitted has to be detected by
something like right so they are like
multiple detection system mostly they
are photomultiplier tubes or some kind
of cameras and ultimately the analog
signal need to be converted into a
digital signal so you need a ADC you
need analog to digital conversion unit
and finally your output would be
displayed in a computer and definitely
at the end you need a certain tube where
your samples would be collected now in
real life this is big more complex
because there could be multiplex laser
modules along with the array of
different detectors different set of
detectors for better understanding of
the morphology complexity of the cell
and even to sort the cells so the key
concept behind flow cytometry is
hydrodynamic focusing so what do you
think about hydrodynamic focusing the
word saves it all hydrodynamic leads to
focusing so hydro dot let's talk about
what is hydrodynamics so imagine there
is a fluid which is the light blue fluid
inside and there are like multiple
different cells inside that fluid
suspended in that fluid now there would
be another fluid surrounding that fluid
stream so this surrounding fluid is
known as she'd fluid and if the sheild
fluid is flowing at a very high rate it
would focus all the substances inside
the pore fluid into a streamline motion
and this is called the hydrodynamic
focusing so hydrodynamic focusing in
hydrodynamic focusing the sheet fluid
and the core fluid system plays a vital
role and it ensures that at the end all
the particles are traveling at the same
axis with the approximate same velocity
so this is the core concept of a flow
cytometry now we can really change the
fluid pressure on the she'd or the
pressure difference between a core and
the shield to change the sorting ability
of the faqs order so now the best way to
get good result is to use a low
concentration of cell and sort it as low
as possible for better results now let's
look at the sorting system so here is
our hydrodynamic focusing system the
important fluidic system of the flow
cytometer which is focusing the cells in
a streamlined manner with the same
velocity and now
a laser is a laser cheek post or
interrogation point is there but make
sure the laser should not directly hit
the detector or otherwise the detector
would go blind right so you need a
neutral density filter to block the
straight laser now at the same time
whenever the cells
whenever the cells would pass through
the laser there would be scattering of
the laser light right pretty simple and
what the detector does is to collect the
scattering light the scattering light
which are like a low angle are collected
by this forward scatter detector and
these light scatter which is collected
by the forward scatter detector and any
other detector can tell us a lot about
its complexity and size and we would
know how other than like forward scatter
light could be scattering in any other
direction all the directions like any
light scatter which is of a higher angle
can be diverted into another side
scattered detector and that could give
us another readout an important
parameter now let's talk about the
forward scatter first in its
characteristics
so imagine to situation in situation one
there is a big sail and in a situation
to there is a small sail so forward
scatter is kind of proportional to the
size of the sample or the cell if the
cell is big forward scatter would be the
magnitude of forward scatter is big and
if the cell is small the forward scatter
would be also small but apart from
forward scatter light can be also bent
into higher angles which would be
detected by side scatter detectors now
light would be scattered in higher
angles when the cellular complexity is
more when the light would really get a
lot of obstruction in while passing
through the sample right so a complex
sample would scatter light in more
different direction so the side scatter
would be more for a very complex sample
right so side scatter is kind of
proportional to complexity or
granularity of the
now all this fluidic system which
focuses the sale and the detection
system the PMT's would give you a
readout of cell count and the forward
scatter just like you can see the graphs
here but individually the forward
scatter data or the side scatter data
doesn't mean that much but we can
combine these two side scatter and the
forward scatter data to form like
special scatter plots where we can
identify special populations and
characteristics about that okay this
might not be very clear at this moment
let me give you an example so here you
can see all the three colors
corresponding to three different
populations but let us take a real-life
example so let's say we want to
differentiate between all the cell
populations present in our blood it
would be RBC is there would be WBC's
even in the WBC's there would be like
several type of WBC's having some
granular side some a granulocytes etc
right so imagine these three populations
the population at the top could
correspond to a very complex and
granular structure so look at these blue
population you can see the side scatter
is quite a lot as well as the forward
scatter is not so you can derive to
conclusion that these cell population is
pretty big because it has high sites the
forward scatter and also it's pretty
complex because it has high side scatter
as well compared to this green
population which has low forward scatter
and low side scatter as well you can see
based on the forward scatter and the
light scattering information we can
really group the cell into different sub
categories and not only grouping and
getting information about them and about
their morphology we can also sort them
out differently for further usage right
that's the best thing about flow
cytometry now in my other videos I'll be
talking about fluorescence assisted cell
sorting systems and for now that's it so
if you like my video to be liquid comes
up and don't forget to like share
subscribe thank you